cnn suggests that misinformation from
the right will cause a civil war but
it's the establishment media embrace of
radical critical race theory
that will split the country i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
slash ben i hope you had a wonderful
weekend we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first
let's talk for a second about the fact
that if you're a responsible person you
need to make sure that you can get life
insurance for your family policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why would you compare
well first you can save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes for policy genius it's a lot of
money you could save 1300 bucks or more
every year on life insurance using
policy genius to compare policies
the license experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of services earn policy genius
a five-star rating across thousands of
reviews on trustpilot and google getting
started super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance you're gonna need
and compare personalized quotes and find
your best price you know everything in
life these days is personalized
and you can shop forward around online
why wouldn't you do the same thing at
policy genius when it comes to something
super important
like life insurance policy genius will
never sell your information to other
companies and policy genius doesn't
add on extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice
and super duper important to get it
right alrighty so
in the absence of donald trump our
establishment media have decided
that now is the moment they can destroy
all opposition it wasn't just that they
were out to get trump
it was that trump was a stand-in for
everybody who didn't think
like they did and now that trump is out
of the picture essentially the
democrats in the establishment media
have decided it's time to go full
out against not just conservatives but
specifically fox news and so
all of the coverage time that they used
to spend on cnn on donald trump has been
shifted
and now they just covered tucker carlson
as though tucker carlson's an elected
official they just cover fox news the
same way the media matters would they
just assign staffers to watch fox news
and you actually want to watch fox news
all you have to do these days is tune in
to cnn because they spend more time
covering what's going on on fox news on
cnn than they do
actually covering what's going on with
the biden administration which is
pursuing
extraordinarily radical plans and all of
their reporters are cheered for this
sort of stuff so jim acosta
who is just a terrible reporter he was a
terrible white house reporter all he
wanted to do
was get on tv it's all he cared about
was those viral clips of jim acosta
shouting at president trump well now
he has nothing to do like he his job is
basically over
because trump isn't there so he has to
pick new enemies and the way that jim
acosta is going to
keep his numbers up is by cursing at fox
news which of course
if you're watching cnn presumably you
like so jim acosta went viral over the
weekend
because he started dropping curse words
on sienna to show how passionate he was
he started dropping
curse words on cable news and so here he
was talking
about fox news and fox news being a
promulgator of lies and all the rest of
jim acosta's usual shtick
as the old saying goes a lie can travel
around the world and back again while
the truth is still
lacing up its boots but the lie the lies
these days are moving at the speed of
light while spreading so much darkness
take for example the uproar over this
new york post story that claimed that
copies of a children's book written by
vice president kamal harris were being
given to migrant kids in their welcome
kits
that tale from the border didn't just
border on bs
this was usda grade a
and the reporter who wrote the story
resigned claiming she was forced to make
it up
but the damage was done pumped out over
the airwaves
at the bull factory also known as fox
news the fox news is a bs factory right
in jim acosta
who is just a promulgator of
self-aggrandizing nonsense
a person who his twitter profile for a
while
was a picture of him looking in a mirror
of him on his twitter profile it was it
was like an infinite regress
of of self-absorption he makes narcissus
look like moses in terms of his humility
it's unreal how
self-aggrandizing and self-obsessed jim
acosta is which is why i always say
ladies find you a man who loves you like
jim acosta
loves jim acosta but this sort of stuff
is sort of par for the course over at
cnn
so jake tapper who occasionally does ask
good questions on his show
i've praised when i think jake does the
right thing this is jake doing the wrong
thing so jake decides that the
republican party is no longer
fact-based as opposed to presumably the
democratic party see the entire subtweet
here is that if you're on
cnn's side of the political aisle this
means that you care about the facts an
apple is an apple and a banana is a
banana
except when an apple has a banana in
which case the apple might be a banana
in any case
here is jake tapper talking about how
the republican party just like fox news
is not fact-based
the incentive structure in the
republican party and its
media does not punish those who spread
bad medical advice or lies in fact quite
the opposite
telling the truth as a republican
official can be hazardous
to your political health it's my opinion
that the united states needs a healthy
thriving
fact-based republican party
it is difficult to look at these events
all of them just from the last week and
conclude that we have one
now i'm not going to praise the new york
post coverage on that kamala hara story
which turned out not to be true
i'm not going to praise the coverage
that suggested that joe biden had
actively proposed that 90
of meat consumption be dumped in the
united states because that active
proposal was non-existent i'm not going
to praise
bad coverage at the same time i am going
to point out
that the sort of high horse coverage
from cnn is something to
really admire i mean the gall of these
folks is something to really admire
because it turns out that the
establishment media don't just get
stories wrong on a regular basis they
pervert the minds of their viewers in
doing so
so the establishment media likes to
point to polls that show that a huge
percentage of republicans
say that joe biden didn't actually win
the 2020 election
i agree that's not good joe biden won
the 2020 election i said this
i've said this repeatedly in fact i've
said this since the electoral college
voted
and i said that i didn't see the full
evidence of
the full evidence of voter fraud and
irregularity that donald trump had
suggested in fact that donald trump
didn't even claim in a wide variety of
cases across the united states
i've been saying that for a while and so
no argument for me that when it comes to
the actual outcome of the 2020 election
joe biden won
all right fair enough i've also said
that i think that the media effectively
rigged the election by lying to you for
months on end about what was going on
with covet
lied to you for months on end about what
was going on with black lives matter in
the in america's major cities
lied to you openly about things like the
hunter biden story or hit it
and all of that can be true at once but
i'm not going to pretend that i think
that it's good that a lot of republicans
say that the 2020 election
was the result of voter fraud and
irregularity
okay i also i'm fairly certain that when
you look at those poll numbers i think
that's a lot of republican voters who
are getting called by pollsters they're
asked the question they understand the
question is a litmus test for loyalty
and so they just say screw you to the
pollster so i think even a lot of the
people who say that
don't in their heart of hearts actually
believe it but put that aside let's
assume that's true
let's assume for a second that the
republican party
puts out information that is not true
and that sometimes fox news
or right-wing media put out things that
are not true let's assume that's all the
case
the converse is so much more true
that it's astounding okay it has been
true for literally my entire lifetime
that false narratives promulgated by the
establishment media have taken
root in the american psyche to the
extent that entire political movements
have been built up around these lies
i can cite you three polls just from the
last few weeks
demonstrating just how deeply the mind
rot promulgated by the establishment
media
has crept into american politics
particularly on the left
i'll get to some of these polls in just
one second because again the idea from
the left
is that america is falling apart and the
reason america is falling apart is
because of this right-wing
misinformation and disinformation and
fox news and the republican party and
all this
the reality is that if the country is
falling apart
if the country is being put to the brink
it is being put to the brink by a
radical group of people in establishment
media who have promulgated
absolute lies large scale lives not tiny
lies like kamala harris
had a had a book distributed at the
border not not small stories
like joe biden wants to cut 90 percent
of meat big stories about what america
is
about what happens in america stories
that go to the root of what the country
ought to be
those stories which are absolute lies
are promulgated by the media routinely
and regularly and they have an impact
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let's talk about a fantastic gift for
mother's day now mother's day is coming
up it's a great time to get
your wife your mom the woman in your
life it's time to get her some jewelry
but what is the best place to get her
jewelry let me tell you about the pearl
source
at the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry at up to 70
off retail prices pearl source cuts out
the middle man by eliminating
traditional five times markups by
jewelry stores
and selling directly to you the consumer
they have the largest selection of
pearls available anywhere each jewelry
piece is custom made for you
the pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order with
zero contact delivery
everything comes beautifully packaged in
an elegant jewelry box so it's ready to
be given as a gift
it comes that no hassle 60 day money
back guarantee so it is absolutely
risk-free don't overpay for jewelry go
to the pearl source save up to 70
off retail prices today i have gotten
jewelry from the pearl source for my
wife it is some of her favorite stuff to
wear is just beautiful i know the people
who own the pearl source
wonderful family people it's a it's a
terrific company
and the people who own it are honest as
the day is long for a limited time
listeners to my show can take 20
off your entire order for mother's day
go to thepearlsource.com
enter promo code bennett checkout for 20
off your entire order if you want fine
pearl jewelry at the best prices online
go straight to the source the pearl
source again that's thepearlsource.com
enter promo code ben at checkout to get
started and take 20 off your entire
order plus again it's already 70
off retail prices it's excellent
excellent stuff alrighty so
when we talk about misinformation and
the deep impact that it has
on how americans think it is worthy of
note that
when you look at the polls on how
dangerous for example americans thought
kovid was
democrats are way off way off
okay so here is a poll this is from
mid-march 2021
what are the chances someone with covid
must be hospitalized
so the actual answer is one to five
percent that if you get coveted
your chances just on average and again
it's much lower than one to five percent
of your child for example
and which is nearly zero percent but
forget about the age tranches
if you listen to this show you know what
the percentage is okay you know the
percentage is one to five percent that's
the actual answer
and 26 of 26 of republicans say that it
is
one to five percent and four percent of
republicans say that it is zero
okay which and another fifteen percent
say that it is six to ten percent
so all in all you're talking about 45
percent of republicans saying
that the chances of being hospitalized
are less than 10 which is correct
okay now look at the democrats for the
democrats only 26
of democrats say there is a less than 10
percent chance of being hospitalized if
you get covered
the number one answer from democrats for
how often
what are the chances that somebody with
covet has to be hospitalized 41 percent
of democrats say that over half of
people who get coveted have to be
hospitalized
over half okay you know why that is
because they all read the new york times
because there is the panic driven
coverage
of the mainstream media it's because
they watch cnn it's because they are
told by the mainstream media day in and
day out that if you get coveted you are
going to die
all in all 69 of democrats say
that if you get coveted there is a an
above 20
chance that you are going to be
hospitalized so they're just dead wrong
they are way off
and it's not just on things like covet
it's also on things like
police shootings so there's a poll that
was done from skeptic.com and it tried
to assess
how many people in america thought how
many black americans were shot
every year by the police unarmed black
americans were shot by the police in
2019.
so the actual answer the real answer is
about 10.
right it's like somewhere between 10 and
20 is the number of unarmed black men
killed by the police
in 2019. okay very conservative people
got this answer right
46 percent of very conservative people
said
that the answer was about 10. another 34
of conservative americans very
conservative americans said about a
hundred
right so certainly well below 100. if
you look at very liberal people
if you look at very liberal people the
number one answer was about one thousand
about a thousand okay and if you look at
the the tale on that another fifteen
percent thought that it was ten thousand
and another eight percent thought it was
more than ten thousand people
black americans were killed unarmed by
the cops every year that is because of
media coverage it's because the media
lie
is because the media tell you untruths
they create narrative untruths on a
regular basis
and for all the talk about how
republicans think the 2020 election was
stolen
let us not forget that a huge number of
democrats thought in the aftermath of
2016 that the 2016 election was stolen
november 18th 2016 the federalist
reports nearly half of democrats thought
the 2016 presidential election was quote
unquote rigged
42 percent of democrats believed that
the election was rigged 58
of democrats responded that donald trump
was legitimately elected on november 8th
okay so if we're talking about just
baseline misinformation
operating in a non-fact-based universe
there is no monopoly on misinformation
and untruth
and if we're talking about deep and
abiding real narratives
the democrats have promulgated
narratives that are significantly
less true about the united states than
the republicans have
and again they make mistakes on a fairly
regular basis over the weekend for
example
the new york times the washington post
they all had to retract a report about
the fbi's communication
with former president trump's longtime
lawyer rudy giuliani according to
dailywire.com the post on thursday was
the first to report that giuliani was
explicitly warned by the fbi
he was the target of a russian effort to
influence the 2020 presidential election
setting unnamed sources identified only
as people familiar with the matter
the washington post also said the
conservative news network one american
news oen
was warned by the by the fbi but on
saturday the post put out a correction
noting that he removed both assertions
the paper said
an earlier version of this story
published thursday incorrectly reported
that one american news was worn by the
fbi it was the target of a russian
influence operation
that version also said the fbi had
provided a similar warning to rudy
giuliani
this version has been corrected to
remove assertions that oann
and giuliani receive the warning so
let's get them a big deal because if
you're warned that the russians are
trying to influence you then you go
ahead and do it anyway that's a problem
but it turns out none of that was true
but it was promulgated by the new york
times and the washington post that is a
major media screw-up
obviously hey so when it comes to just
that if you're talking about like the
magnitude of stories that get screwed up
one you're saying that the president's
personal lawyer rudy giuliani
was told by the fbi the russians were
trying to use him
and then he ignored it and that one
american news a right-wing media outlet
heavily associated with trump
was being used by the russians and they
were told by the fbi that they were
being used
by the russians that story then gets
pulled down by both the washington post
and the new york times on the other hand
you have cnn blanket covering
a story about whether joe biden
suggested that 90 percent of meat
consumption in the united states would
have to decline which one of those
stories do you think is more important
like if it had been promulgated which
one of the stories is more important
that the president's personal lawyer was
basically enthralled of the russians and
was warned by the fbi that he was
or that joe biden wants to cut meat
consumption
okay when it comes to the depth and
breadth of the narratives that are
pushed by the media that are damaging to
the country
the establishment media are way worse
than anything fox news or the republican
party has
has to promulgate here and that is not
to make light of some of the things that
the republican party
has promulgated including doubts about
the veracity of the 2020 election
outcome
okay you don't have to make light of one
in order to condemn both
and to say that one is of greater
magnitude than the other i don't have to
make light of january 6.
in order in order to say that i truly
believe the authoritarian threat to the
country
does not come primarily from the drugs
and morons who decided to run into the
capitol building on january 6.
it comes from the control of all major
institutions in american society by a
militant left that wishes to cram down
its view its perverse view of utopian
america on you
i'm capable of differentially assessing
threats and risks
and i don't have to make light of one in
order to in order to promote
the notion that the other is more
dangerous we'll get to the true threats
to the country and how the establishment
media are basically
apparently they're spoiling for a sort
of civil war in this country at this
point we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about your safety and
security at home so you got a lot going
on at your house i got a lot going on at
my house i got a lot of people showing
up on the
on the porch they're dropping off
packages we have people who are stopping
by more and more these days as the
pandemic wanes right
a lot is going on and that's great i
also want to make sure i know what the
hell is going on in my house i have
three kids under the age of seven
so this is why i rely on ring ring
allows me to keep an eye on my home no
matter where i am right from my phone
and ring has hassle free easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams so you'll never
miss a visitor you can keep those
packages and delivery safe with motion
detection you'll get notified even if
they don't ring the doorbell
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know which is
awesome
there's a special offer on the ring
welcome kit available at ring.com
ben right now it comes with the ring
video doorbell 3 and the chime pro
don't wait get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com
ben it comes with that ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience
head on over to ring.com that is
ring.com go check them out right now
ring.com for that special offer on the
ring welcome kit my wife and i rely on
ring you should too they are great
ring.com that is ring.com
okay so when i say that the
establishment media are spoiling for
something here that they are spoiling
to to divide the country pit it against
itself
it's not just that they condemn people
on the right as as pushing
misinformation that's a commonality in
politics that's been going on as long as
i've been alive democrats call
republicans liars republicans call
democrats liars
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about the establishment media
promoting narratives about the nature of
the country
that are just awful and that lead to
tremendously deep and profound conflict
most of the political conflict that we
tend to see on a day-to-day basis you
know politicians arguing with each other
that's basically penguins slapping each
other on top of the iceberg i'm talking
about the nature of the iceberg itself
democrats are trying to crack the
iceberg that we all share and they are
trying to divide it so that the two
halves have to float away from each
other
and so for example cnn's reliable
sources so reliable so sources
they had a panel in which they suggested
the right-wing media could incite civil
war the right-wing media is going to
incite civil war but as we will see
if anybody is going to promote radical
ideas that are likely to divide the
country down the middle
it's going to be cnn and the democrats
here is the cnn panel
it is not a an equivalent uh holy war an
equivalent
sectarianism uh but so much of what
you're talking about in the undermining
of democracy is coming from
the right and so i don't know if
sectarianism kind of washes out the
difference between
um different sides of the political
spectrum seems to me
uh post-trump uh you certainly are
fact-checking biden and we're going to
get into your new data about that in a
minute
but a lot of what you're doing now is
fact-checking right-wing media because
it's the new york post it's fox news
that's advancing these false narratives
okay so the we're on the verge of a
civil war it's one side
that was a professor at columbia and
then there's brian stelter who's talking
to daniel dale who has been basically
put on the back burner now daniel dale
was the guy who would kind of
fire hose everything that trump ever
said that was exaggerated or false
and talk about what a damned liar trump
was now he soft pedals what biden says
that's false and spends his time and you
hear brian stelter say
checking fox news which is deeply deeply
important stuff
okay what kind of narratives are being
promoted by the sectarian-left media
the narrative that america is
systemically racist and that people who
oppose systemic racism
the the idea that america is
systemically racist people who say that
that's not true
are in fact the villains in american
society and need to be excised from the
public debate
so cnn's w camo bell over the weekend
he i mean you're telling me that the the
the person the people who are promoting
civil war in the country are people on
the right
that's what you're telling me here's w
camo bell appearing with dino badaya
both of whom are cnn contribs on
siriusxm's dinobodia show talking about
how he doesn't even know that the
country is worth fighting for
what are we fighting for in this country
as black folks like
are we is is this country worth fighting
for and i think especially
through covid and through trump and
trump's response to covet
and through the fact that covert has
made this made
the lives of black latinx indigenous and
brown folks worse
and made it so that we that whatever
hole that our communities were in the
hole is deeper now and we've lost a ton
of people
we lost other people through covet that
you go
is this all worth fighting for and
that's the place where i'm at now is
like
in a very really profound way go yeah i
don't i don't know how much more that i
can personally do
okay so is this worth fighting for is
this country worth fighting for you
haven't
camo bell is not like out of the
mainstream here the left has decided
in by definition deeply unpatriotic
fashion that america is rooted in evil
that america is rooted in systemic
racism that all of its institutions are
shot through
with racism and the media love this
narrative this is the this is the
biggest lie that is being told in
american politics right now
is that americans america's institutions
are irrevocably
irredeemably racist and terrible and
anybody who refuses to say that
is by dental refusing to say that a
racist and the media are reflecting this
every single day and they they just lie
in order to promote that idea
that this is like a deep that this is a
deeply felt
and and widely held view in the united
states they're taking a fringe view
about what the united states
is and they've rammed it into the
mainstream and the bite administration
is promoting it quite openly
at this point so for example it is the
biden administration and the left in the
united states that has promoted the idea
that the education department of the
united states
ought to be taken over essentially by
critical race theory that they they
ought to
ram into place a notion that critical
race theory
which we'll get into in just one second
should be taught the department of
education put out a series of guidelines
in which they recommended
that if you want a grant one of the ways
you can get a grant is by teaching the
garbage 6019 project which is a
pseudo-history of the united states in
which the revolutionary war was fought
to preserve slavery
a lie and also in which uber max kennedy
the greatest race grifter in america
right now
ought to be taught and if you do that
maybe you get a federal grant from the
department of education
so this is a view of the of america that
is being promoted at the highest levels
in our media
and it's being mainstreamed in our
colleges and it's being mainstreamed
in the federal government of the united
states and the media are pushing this
thing they are pushing it
so unbelievably hard right now we're
gonna get to that in just one second
they're lying in order to promote it
i'll get to that in one second first
let us talk about the fact that one of
the worst things that you can do
financially is get into credit card
trouble if you start racking up those
credit cards
and then you just let the interest rates
go you will find yourself in a world of
hurt instead if you're a responsible
person
you really need to make sure that you
consolidate those credit card loans and
get out of that credit card debt like
asap if you're looking for a way to save
extra money why not start by paying less
interest on that credit card balance
refinance with a credit card
consolidation loan
from lightstream it's an easy way to
save hundreds or thousands of dollars
and lower your interest rate
lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans from 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
they have lower than average credit card
interest rates
uh those ones are like over 18 apr and
there are no fees you can even get your
money as soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
that's exactly
what they deliver again if you get
caught in credit card trouble it can
absolutely destroy your life don't let
that be you
just for my listeners apply right now
get a special interest rate discount
save even more the only way to get the
discount is to go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's
l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject credit approval rate
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.50 auto
pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply and offers
are subject to change without notice
visit lightstream.com
shapiro for more information alrighty so
the media have decided that they're
going to push
hard for the idea that critical race
theory is popular and that america
really should have a giant fight over
whether america is institutionally
racist
they're doing this because the
democratic party has decided that this
is their pathway to victory
so for a long time there were two there
was a conflict inside the democratic
party that nobody could square
one was the idea the government solved
all your problems this was sort of the
lbj
fdr idea the government was the solution
and the other was the critical race
theory
idea that america's systems and
institutions not only couldn't solve all
your problems they were all systemically
racist then barack obama came along and
he said in his very personage
it's true all the systems of the united
states are in fact racist and bad but
i'm here on the inside i'm gonna wreck
those systems
and this has been the the baton that has
been picked up by this old
this geriatric daughter the current
president of the united states joe biden
he's picked this up and he's run with it
the idea being that you're right all the
institutions of the united states are
racist and you're redeemably so and so
we're going to change those institutions
from the inside it's not about using the
institutions to do good it's about
systemically changing the institutions
from the inside the revolutionaries are
on the inside and so this is being
pushed
by the media and the american people it
turns out in most areas of the united
states are not real fond of this crap
they do not like the idea that has been
promoted that critical race theory is a
good idea
now before i go any further let me
actually explain what critical race
theory is because people don't seem to
understand what critical race theory is
critical race theory is the idea that
america's institutions are deeply racist
and that all of america is deeply racist
the way that you get to this conclusion
and the sort of origins of critical race
theory really start
with critical theory critical theory was
a marxist notion
and that was that america's institutions
promote repression and tyranny
because they are rooted in capitalism
critical theory says
all of america's institutions all of our
higher flown ideals in the declaration
of independence
and the constitution of the united
states all of that is just crap
it's just cover for systems of power for
hierarchies of power and those are meant
to enshrine class differences
and so they have to be torn away so we
can have a non-fascist non-class-based
society now there's only one problem
with the critical theory argument in
general
america is not a class-based society
america's never been a class-based
society alexis de tocqueville talked
very early on in american history about
how what was unique about america is
that there didn't seem to be these very
rigid classes people moved in and out of
classes there was this burgeoning middle
class a huge middle class
everybody seemed to have a certain
amount of property in the united states
tocqueville talks about this in
democracy in america which is being
written in the 1830s
so the class-based argument about
american society didn't hold a lot of
sway in the united states
but the race-based argument that
america's institutions
are shot through with racism at least up
to the 1960s there was truth to that
because
america's institutions actually legally
discriminated
if you went down to south if you went
down south there were actual legal
systems of discrimination in place if
you go back
before the civil war slavery was
actually legal in the united states
and of course there were federal laws on
the books that forced
states that were free to return slaves
who'd been who'd escaped
from these awful places right so
the the argument that america's
institutions historically
had racism in them is true
the argument that was made by by
traditional american patriots ranging
from frederick douglass to american
to to abraham lincoln was that america's
institutions all had also
were written with the ability to
self-correct and the and the higher
ideals of the united states
were not in fact mere enshrinements of
hierarchical power
but were the baton you could use in
order to break these racial systems in
these racial hierarchies
okay but critical race theory basically
took the marxist theory of class
and then extended it to race so all of
america's institutions
were shot through with race and were
therefore un
unredeemable or irredeemable and
unfixable
stokely carmichael uh was the probably
the first person to start using the term
systemically racist or structural or
institutionally racist he was doing that
around 1966 when he was the head of the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee later on he'd become a black
separatist and the head of a black
panther party
carmichael posited that while the
federal government had barred
discrimination on the basis of race
racism could not be alleviated by such
action see the problem for critical
race theorists is that america barred
discrimination on the basis of race in
1965.
so they had to have some other
explanation for why the institutions had
to be torn down
because just as the united states had
been not based in class now the united
states was moving away from hierarchies
of race
thank god but people on the left
wanted to tear down the systems
nonetheless so they had to come up with
some explanation of how america was
still racist and indeed in some ways
more racist than it was
when racism was legal and enshrined in
law
carmichael wasn't arguing the system
could be mobilized on behalf of people
it did victimize
he was arguing the definition of racism
itself would have to change you'd
necessarily have to see somebody being a
racist
enough to see a racist intent in law his
argument was now that if there was any
inequality of outcome
that meant that the system itself was
racist
now again in 1965 maybe that has some
truck because
you are literally living in a system
where legal racism has just been ended
and so you can't expect it
all the outcomes are going to shift
overnight what you would expect is they
would shift over time
okay but this the critical race theory
project really takes off in the late 70s
and the early 80s
the chief expositors were a couple of
people called richard delgado and
and jean stefancek and they set out the
basic principles of crt
critical race theory the first principle
was that racism is ordinary and not
aberrational so when you say that
somebody is racist you have to
understand that that's not an insult
when you say somebody is racist what
you're really saying is they are just a
person
and then they have to be trained to be
not just a person they have to be
trained to be better
second our system of white over color
ascendancy serves important purposes
both psychic and material
in other words the system is designed to
create racially desperate outcome and
people hold on to
those racially disparate outcomes and if
you like the system it's because
secretly you have some sort of clinging
to and cleaving to
these racial hierarchies critical race
theory pioneer
derek bell who is very close with barack
obama
he wrote that quote the whole liberal
world view of private rights and public
sovereignty
mediated by the rule of law needed to be
exploded right understand that this is
the goal behind critical race theories
to destroy all the institutions right
private property public sovereignty all
of this needs to be thrown away private
rights
a world view premised upon public and
private spheres is an attractive mirage
that masks the reality of economic and
political power in other words what
derek bell was arguing
is that everything needs to be regulated
by the government the private is public
the public is private
you see this and how joe biden talks
about the role of government
according to derek bell even purportedly
good outcomes for black people
could be evidence of white supremacy
implicit within the system
because white people are so invested in
the system they would even be willing to
allow things like barack obama being
elected just to uphold the system
and so this is the critical race theory
garbage that people are attempting to
now cram into the public schools here's
the thing
and this is promoted in america's major
newspapers the 1619 project
is rife with critical race theory
garbage
in fact this is why nicole hannah jones
the de facto editor and
pseudo-journalist at the new york times
is out there defending critical race
theory today
right she's very big into critical race
theory she's been a fan for quite a
while
okay well here's the thing this sort of
stuff not super
popular not super popular for
the for for all of this to take root in
america's educational systems and people
around the united states are saying
listen
especially with school kids one thing to
do this psychologist especially for
school kids
local school boards get to set the
agenda for what gets taught in schools
this has always been true there's a
certain viewpoint that will be taught
and there's certain viewpoints that will
not be taught
right when you're talking about how kids
get taught in the united states they
should be taught in a way that suggests
the truth about american history which
is that we have horrible blemishes in
american history but the story of
america
is a constant attempt to live up to
founding principles and it's those
founding principles that were used as
the impetus for change right that's the
way that history
usually was set to be taught in the
united states
but the media don't want it taught that
way and so their suggestion is that
america is deeply divided over this
stuff now the reality is that if
democrats want to keep saying this they
can say it as much as they want it ain't
true
it ain't true okay so we'll get to this
in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are walking around your house
uncomfortably these days you need a
great pair of slippers now
you've heard me talk about my pillow and
how i love their pillow like it makes me
sleep better
it doesn't give me neck pain it's
fantastic well now my pillow has
introduced
my slippers the slippers took over two
years to develop they're designed to
wear indoors or outdoors
all day long they're super duper
comfortable my slippers are made with my
pillow foam
and impact gel to help prevent fatigue
they're made with quality leather suede
i can tell you firsthand these are very
comfortable you're gonna love them the
whole family's gonna want them for a
limited time my pillow is offering 40
off their new my slippers these make a
great mother's day gift by the way 40
off so i've got sheets pillows and
slippers from my pillow like all their
products comfort
is key go to mypillow.com click on that
radio listener square use promo code
daily wire
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
the my pillow towel sets or
call 800-951-7163 use promo code daily
wire visit mypillow.com right now or
call 800-951-7163 remember
use promo code dailywire and you get
some awesome awesome
discounts alrighty we'll get to more on
critical race there and how the media
are promoting
effectively ideological civil war that
could eventually get worse than that
we'll get to that in just a minute first
as i'm sure you all know the daily wire
has been growing
like crazy not only did we move our
whole company across the country we also
released our first feature film we
struck up a movie deal with gina carano
we launched a new talk show hosted by
candace owens that's just within the
last six months
alone and we have huge stuff coming up
for you
and i can tell you that our folks here
are excited to bring you all sorts of
brand new content we launched a bunch
right that's my series
behind the paywall where you can hear me
debunk tom and leftist myths
we have amazing awesome stuff coming for
you i'm so excited for the future of the
company
and we here at the daily wire want to
express our gratitude to you because you
guys make
all of this possible and we want to
continue to include you in our future
plans because we are growing every
single day
every day on my show i talk about a lot
of amazing products and services from
sponsors that i love and use but we want
to get to know you better so we can
choose our sponsors with you in mind so
we can get great discounts on stuff you
want
please go to dailywire.com shapiro fill
out my audience survey
tell us a little more about yourself and
to sweeten that whole experience those
of you who complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000 gift card
which is a pretty sweet deal just for
filling out a survey you can only take
that survey once per daily wire show if
you want to increase your chance of
winning a thousand bucks go listen to
michael moores and reclaivan or matt
walsh get access to their surveys
as well again my survey link is
dailywire.com
shapiro we would love to hear from you
if you didn't see yesterday's episode of
the ben shapiro show sunday special you
are also missing out yesterday
i hosted the one and only jordan
peterson he's everybody's favorite
clinical psychologist and the author of
beyond order 12 more rules for life it's
an awesome interview people are just
loving it
go check it out right now it's the usual
depth of
not only emotion but depth of thought
that you get from jordan go check it out
right now at dailywire.com or on my
youtube channel ben shapiro daily wear
members get access to special bonus
content from sunday special episodes so
do not
miss out join daily wire today and most
important
announcement of the day i am excited to
announce i have a brand new book coming
out
it's a new book it's coming out it is
called the authoritarian moment
today i am pleased to reveal a first
look at this book's cover check this out
oh look at that baby you can see the
jack boot right there the authoritarian
moment how the left weaponized america's
institutions against descent so if
you're worried about what's going on in
the country right now
this is the book that matters i go
institution my institution
we talk about how the left took over
those institutions and most importantly
we talk about
personal strategies you can use to fight
back against the authoritarian moment we
are currently experiencing the leftist
ascendant in every area of american life
we go through each of these areas and
how you can fight back in each of these
areas the authoritarian moment
it's available for pre-order right now
at amazon barnes noble or any other
major bookseller
order your copy today get all the facts
necessary to dispute the leftist in your
life and to fight back
against the authoritarian left which as
i say in the book is the most dangerous
threat to america today the
authoritarian left is on the march
find out how to fight back i'm super
excited about the book i think it's
great i'm doing the audio read the book
right now so you can pre-order that as
well i believe
go check out the authoritarian moment
it's available for pre-order at amazon
barnes noble or any other
major bookseller go check them out right
now you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
okay so here is the thing most americans
don't like this critical race theory
stuff
they don't like it and they don't like
it because it's bad because it's ugly
and because it's untrue
when i say it's bad it's ugly and it's
untrue let me just give you an example
of the kind of opinions it leads you to
so charles blow who's an awful columnist
for the new york times but at least
give him the merit of he says what's on
his mind he doesn't hide the ball he has
a piece in the new york times today it
is titled is america a racist country
he gets to the good part about halfway
down in the piece
he says abraham lincoln said during his
famous debates about against stephen
douglas in 1858 that among white people
and black ones quote there must be the
position of superior and inferior
and i as much as any other man i'm in
favor of the superior position being
assigned to the white man
which is an actual quote from abraham
lincoln in 1858 you know
when he was arguing against slavery
and was transitioning away from the
racism that was inherent in american
society
here but listen to where listen to where
charles blow a black columnist for the
most prestigious newspaper in america
the new york times goes with this
you ready someone can see the historical
point
and insist on the progress point arguing
that was then and this is now
that racism simply doesn't exist now as
it than then
i would agree american racism has
evolved and become less blunt
but it has not become less effective the
knife has simply been sharpened
now systems do the work that once
required the overt actions of masses of
individual racists
okay that's that's just madness i mean
this is where critical race theory leads
to absolute utter madness
that's insane to suggest that systems of
slavery in the united states and jim
crow in the united states
are no less effective than the systems
of racism in place today is insane
okay i don't mean that it's unreasonable
i mean it's literally insane you have to
be a crazy person to believe
this that racism in america in 2021
is more effective or as effective as
slavery and jim crow racism
you also have to be totally crazy to
suggest as charles blow does
that the knife has been sharpened that
now racism is sharper than it was
right it's gotten more effective more
more efficient than it was
during the days of you know enslavement
of black people and treating them as
chattel property
and or the days in which black americans
were barred
from going to the same schools as white
americans were forced to drink at their
own water fountains were forced to take
separate modes of transportation
and were barred from restaurants like
what in the actual f is he talking about
charles blow i'm sure sipping his latte
at a nice restaurant on the upper west
side of manhattan while writing a piece
for the new york times
and i'm sorry this is crazy and he says
systems do the work that once
required the overt actions of masses of
individual races
so um is he unaware that slavery was a
system a legalized system
is he unaware that jim crow was a
legally mandated system
not not just allowed mandated if you go
back to read alabama jim crow laws
it was not restaurants may segregate if
they wish to restaurants
must segregate whether or not they wish
to it was a state
mandate and now he's saying that in
america
in which racism discrimination has been
federally outlawed
since 1965 for night on 50 years
right you're talking over 50 years 55
years since the civil rights act
you're talking here about how america
is more racist or just as racist as it
was then
because its systems are so intertwined
with racism you know the same systems
that have legally barred racism
okay this is a perverse world view it's
a disgusting
a lying world view when i talk about
dishonesty and misinformation this
is utter dishonesty it is misinformation
it is a lie it is a gigantic
lie and is being promoted day in and day
out by your members of the establishment
media who are spoiling for some sort of
ideological civil war here
this is radical horse crap okay and they
are they're promoting it
every single day how are they promoting
it okay so this came up for a vote
okay so in south lake texas they're a
bunch of candidates
and they opposed a local school
diversity plan okay the local school
diversity plan which is an orwellian
name
for a school education plan that was
going to use all these garbage critical
race theory points
there's the school board election the
school board was taken over
70 by 70 30 vote that is not a close
vote 70 30 is a blowout by any standard
a castro like blowout by a 70-30 vote
the school board that was promoting the
critical race theory garbage was tossed
out
and instead people were put in place who
believed in teaching traditional
american history with all of its warts
and all of its flaws
here is how this election remember 70
30. 70 30 was
characterized by nbc news again your
establishment media they say that the
right ones the civil war no no no the
right is just sitting here
we just want to be left alone we want to
be able to teach our kids traditional
american history
you guys are the ones who apparently
want the ideological and maybe more than
that
civil war i can't find any other
explanation here's how nbc news
headlined this
remember seven i keep emphasizing 70 30
elections the headline i'm about to read
is delusional
quote opponents of anti-racism education
so first of all they're already using
the sort of language that is promoted by
the critical race theorists right and
when they promote overt racism
as in white americans are inherently
part of systems of racism
and they have to inc they have to wallow
in supposed systemic and institutional
white guilt
they call themselves anti-racist
educators they are racist ever max kenny
has suggested that discrimination today
is the solution to discrimination of the
past he's a racist
okay but this is anti-racism now send me
nbc news headlines this
opponents of anti-racism education win
big
in a bitterly divided election in south
lake texas conservative candidates who
opposed a school diversity plan won
every local race
taking about 70 percent of the vote in
the wealthy dallas fort worth suburb
so i have a question bitterly divided
election
by what standard is a 70 30 blowout a
bitterly divided election
that's not a bitterly divided election
can you imagine if republicans had lost
that race
it would be in stunning rebuke of
traditional american thought
the radical new magical people
who promote critical race theory win big
right it would be a blowout
the media's headline would have been
blow out 7030 is a blowout it is not a
bitterly divided election but the
headline is a bitterly divided election
on one side says nbc news progressives
argued that curriculum and disciplinary
changes were needed
to make all children feel safe and
welcome in carol a mostly white but
quickly diversifying school district
on the other conservatives in south lake
rejected the school diversity plan
as an effort to indoctrinate students
with a far left ideology that according
to some
would institutionalize discrimination
against white children and those with
conservative christian values
candidates and voters on both sides
described the election as a fork in the
road for south lake
in the end the contest was not close yes
so then why was it bitterly divided it
wasn't
okay they got blown out as well they
should have been
but the media have an interest in
promoting the idea that we are bitterly
divided over the stuff
even though we are not it is the reason
why the media hate tim scott so much
hate him the senator from south carolina
because tim scott correctly points out
the critical race theory is not only
mumbo jumbo it is garbage it is racism
this is why you end up with msnbc's
tiffany cross calling calling tim scott
a sitting united states senator from
south carolina a token and a clown
and sure tim scott has spoken out about
his encounters with law enforcement and
he
co-sponsored the anti-lynching bill in
the senate
but there are two sides to every token
so
thirsty for white approval this dude
actually stood on the national stage
to defend the voter suppression law in
georgia please senator
say more about how unracist the country
is
while you trot out that tired line about
going from cotton
to congress to clown to clowns he's a
clown
he's a token and he's a racist tim scott
these are the folks
who are ginning up civil war in the
country the folks of the radical left in
the establishment media these are the
folks who lie to you every day about the
nature of the country
and they're taking over the institutions
on virtually every front
i mean obviously you have radicals like
maxine waters who've been saying this
sort of stuff for years here's maxine
waters saying that every single day
we've seen this nation get more racist
every single day really
really maxine waters every day in
america we get more racist
weird because i've noticed some
differences between 2021 and say 1861.
namely that you're sitting in congress
saying absolute horse crap
for the giggles and hoots of the media
it's insane
every day we have seen you know this
nation
get more racist than anybody thought
perhaps would be at this point in time
we've been through the civil rights
movement
where of course we made some progress
but this
uh president that we had trump was
taking us backwards
uh and he was making racist comments uh
he was uh
you know identifying himself with people
like
the ku klux klan and the proud boys
and the oath keepers and the uh q anon
i mean that is racism defined
uh in the most uh obvious way okay
racism to find the most obvious way
would be
active discrimination on the basis of
race maxine waters is an open promoter
of that sort of ideology it just depends
on the race
okay meanwhile how how deeply has this
has this crappy message
been intertwined into the institutions
of american life i have a new book
coming out as i mentioned a little bit
earlier called the
earlier called the authoritarian moment
about how america's institutions have
been overtaken
by the radical left and have been
basically weaponized against dissent
it's called the authoritarian moment you
can pre-order it right now comes out in
a couple of months
okay how deeply has this been enshrined
in america's institutions
there's a company a sort of woke venture
capital company called base camp
in silicon valley and base camp's chief
executive
jason fried put out a blog post last
monday in which he said that societal
and political discussions on company
messaging tools were a major distraction
he said that the company would ban
committees cut benefits like a fitness
allowance and stop lingering and
dwelling on past decisions
he said we're actually going to run this
business like a business so one third of
the employees resigned
base camp had 57 employees including mr
freed when the announcement was made
since then at least 20 of them have
posted publicly that they intend to
resign or have already resigned
according to a tally by the new york
times
mr freed and david hansen two of base
camp's founders have published several
books about workplace culture
news of their latest management
philosophy was met with a mix of
applause and criticism
on social media
here's the thing first of all this is a
great way to uh
to purge your company of people who
would be crappy employees anyway if your
employees are so focused on yelling at
each other on message boards about
wokeness
that they're not doing their work it
seems to me that them quitting is an
excellent hr solution
but beyond that it just shows how deeply
enmeshed in american culture the crt
culture has become
the critical race theory ideology has
become
i mean so deeply by the way that the the
idea that we're all supposed to see each
other in quote-unquote intersectional
ways
that we're supposed to build our
institutions not around
quality of performance but we're
supposed to really focus in on
other immutable aspects of ourselves as
though this is what makes an institution
good
is that the institution focuses in on
those things
that that's it that's a weird it's a
weird take and it's it's
really gone up to the highest levels of
american society the cia whose job last
i checked was to implement
american foreign policy abroad the
central intelligence agency right
they're the
foreign sort of bookend to the fbi
domestically
they put out an ad for the cia focusing
on how the cia is focused on
recruiting people who are intersectional
and people have generalized anxiety
disorder and i just
what does this have to do with doing the
job of the cia i'm a woman of color
i am a mom i am a cisgender millennial
who's been diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorder
i am intersectional but my existence is
not a box checking exercise
i am a walking declaration a woman whose
inflection does not rise at the end of
her sentences
suggesting that a question has been
asked i did not sneak into cia
my employment was not and is not the
result of a fluke
or slipped through the cracks okay i
just have a question
what does this have to do with the
efficacy of the of the cia
anything i mean seriously what does she
do for a living i don't even know what
she does at the cia like if you're going
to do an ad for the cia
you might want to focus on what the cia
actually does because that's the part
that should matter to the taxpayers
not the cisgender millennial identity of
the people who work for the cia
the the divide in america is being
caused by the left the left plays this
game
where they they do deeply radical things
then they blame people for noticing you
should notice and you should fight back
against it because the takeover instead
of our institutions by a deeply
disturbed
philosophy of what america is is the
biggest lie being told about america
it's being promulgated by your
establishment media
is being promulgated by the leaders of
the white house it's being promulgated
in every major institution in america
life
in american life and it needs to be
countered it needs to be countered right
to hell now
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show in the meantime
go check out the michael moles show
that's available right now i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a major tech company tells its woke
employees to shut up
romney gets booed by the utah gop and
maxine waters says america gets
more racist every day go check it out on
the michael knowles show